oh
hello
omg
[Music]
we are out here
hello everyone
what's goodie as we say here
what's good what goodie welcome to the
100 joe contest everyone let me get my
bearings
i've literally
been up since 7 30
planting you're not gonna believe it
but
a pink gardening
most of the mornings let me get my
bearings here
not to brag or anything but got some
echinacea
some salvia maybe a little little
butterfly bush you know
so it's good to see all y'all in here we
are
we're getting it together right now baby
we're getting it together as peeps are
coming in we got chicken joe clark
what's goodie fam
joe said morning hop breather and
sisters good to see you jack allen in
the building joan
ed rubin joan fuchsman bob kirk
bain bear
good to see you fam jerry
welcome to the hot breath garden show
yes indeed and i want to is it
jerry kroll cruel
i want to make sure i pronounce it right
because jerry is one of the finalists i
believe a first time
participant
and he's already a finalist so
this is going to be cool man every
single month we do this
we do this crawl as in dull crawl dull
perfect thank you very much jerry
appreciate that buddy
as someone who has been in this game
long enough to know
i've had my name pronounced every which
away joel jowl
joelle jal
bars bowers
i had a flyer recently spell my name
b-u-y
e-r-s
my name is spelled b-y-a-r-s but they
really took it literally
and making it maybe the worst spelling
ever
mike metta mike mata
in here first timer i'm excited
let's go
welcome mike
yeah yeah so as we're coming in here
peeps hit that like button let's see if
we can get this algorithm in rhythm a
little bit let some other peeps find us
so do hit that like button if you
haven't already subscribe to this
youtube channel as well and
help us make comedy history together
but what we're doing today my friends
is our monthly hundred dollar joke
contest what happens here every month at
the hot breath verse
is graduates of our comedy writing
master class
compete every month
in a contest where we get a
new theme and comics get two weeks to
write a brand new 90 second set
based on that theme now this month's
theme
was pets
you know i like to do um
a little more generic
uh
or like some i like to do personal broad
topics hoping that people are then
writing material
that um they actually translate to the
stage and i know a lot of people that
participate in this every month actually
uh use it just to have accountability to
write
new material every month that they can
then take to the stage so
it's a great accountability piece it's a
great challenge as well and
it's a great way to make 100 bucks i
mean come
on i know
hundred dollar holla
the winner today gets a hundred bucks
and an interview on hot press podcast
the world famous
hot breath podcast
so buckle up my friends how this is
gonna work
is we have three finalists
let's pull them up here because they
worked hard we got jerry kroll sandra
doss and jack allen allen
isn't that fun
so anyway
so they're competing this month shout
out to everyone that did compete in this
month's contest we had a few new faces
and we had a few faces we hadn't seen in
a while i mean to do this
every single month
is not easy
and i can tell you from personal
experience from someone who's like oh
yeah i'm gonna do it this month and then
time flies so
yeah so um
i'm trying to get my blazer all right
but um
yes that's the name of the game
basically what we're gonna do today is
i'm gonna play all three sets and then
we're gonna vote
you
are gonna vote live on the live stream
and the winner gets to come on the show
live for a hot breath interview and
they're going to win 100 bucks so
it's a big deal
and then i get to go back to planting
plants
[Music]
mowing milan cause i'm gonna be in
myrtle beach all next week so if
anyone's in that area i'm working the
comedy cabana all weekend so holla at ya
bisoy
from the myrtle beach area
oh and la verana
optimista said everyone is clever
yeah this is yeah these are going to be
some fun sets here and oh and aaron
despiva i almost missed you there buddy
he said good morning right tenors hello
hello
[Music]
so what do y'all say
y'all y'all ready to jump into this
y'all ready to go ahead and jump into
this the the the order will be as
follows it'll be jack allen then jerry
crowell
and then sandra doss
so those are going to be the three
competitors this
morning or evening or
afternoon wherever you are around the
world we appreciate you watching and
hanging out with us
but without further ado are y'all ready
to kick this off
holla at your biz away shouty
thank you to everyone that showed love
for um
i did a pediatric cancer fundraiser
this
uh this weekend this friday so the best
thing about comedy is
um
on friday i was at a pediatric cancer
foundation fundraiser which i've worked
with him for a few years now
i've like a mentored a young cancer
survivor named ethan who's now in fifth
grade but kind of gave him his first
stage time and if we've kept in touch
and we've just done done fun things you
know so that's the fun thing about
comedy you never know where it's gonna
take you
so i went friday
at a pediatric cancer foundation
fundraiser
and then saturday
i'm on the south side of atlanta
doing shows with tk kirkland which if
you guys
are familiar with tk kirkland um you
know what a contrast it is
from
hoity-toity cancer fundraiser
to then
tk kirkland and if you don't know
just um just google just give
give tk kirkland a google and you will
you will see what i mean actually look
him up on youtube because you want to
see his comedy in action
but long story short he's absolutely
hilarious he's been doing this since
1985.
he's just one of those comics that
literally
just says what he feels and holds
and takes no prisoners
and i will say um
last night and just for a little context
here he is
just for a little context uh
there he is for you there
um
but i've done shows with him for years
now
anytime he comes to atlanta he usually
requests for me to open for him so i've
worked with him several times so um
he did 90 minutes
two shows last night each show he did 90
minutes
um
which was very impressive
but that meant i was out until like
1 30 last night you know and then up
early planting and then look at us here
making comedy history together
but yeah just look just look up some of
his bits on youtube and you'll be like
oh that is not a a um
a cancer fundraiser event
all right well it sounds like we're
ready to go here
pete in the building
pete says jerry jerry jerry
said your check cleared so i'm here well
thanks for hanging out pete thanks for
coming in here
this is hot breath we have over 400
interviews
with some of the top comics in the game
so hang out subscribe to the youtube
channel if you haven't
and
let's get into it my friends shall we
there's the applause we're looking for
[Applause]
wait
there we go
oh sandy bernstein in the building
hey hey
sandra dahl says hi everybody all right
so we are ready to rock bane bear
oh my gosh
look at this bane bear said
i love this channel well thank you so
much baine bear and we love you as well
my friend
and sandy in the building one of our
previous winners she's won it several
times i think she actually won last
month
actually um but sandy i'm at comedy
cabana all weekend and i posted a flyer
i mean all this upcoming week and
someone commented saying i was a cabana
boy and i immediately thought of your
joke
about cabana boys
but that being said
my friends
are you ready are you ready
are you
ready where's the
oh there it is
yes cabana boy yep very nice yeah and if
you want to hear sandy's interview it is
on the podcast you can go listen to that
wherever you listen to your favorite
podcast apple spotify
we are all of them shawty
we ain't new to this we grew to this fam
all right
so let's
get into it my friends
we're gonna play jack allen
then jerry kroll
and then sandra doss
they're all 90 second sets they're nice
quick sets and just think as you're
watching this my wife and i always watch
all the submissions
and we pick the top three for then you
to vote to see who wins
and just a few things we're looking for
here one
how did they use the theme the theme
this month is pets so look at how
creative they were with the theme and
how they incorporated it into their sets
and in their writing
uh number two
you know also just how funny is it at
the end of the day like you know it just
quick comedy tip you know you want to
open with a laugh as quick as possible
and you want to close with a laugh and
you want to get as many laughs in
between as possible so just look at
just how purely funny the set is how
many laughs are in this set and that can
be a good kind of gauge for how you
determine
um
because it can be a tight race and even
to get to the top three my wife and i
had to really watch a few sets and be
like well
this one was funny but this one was more
like structured this one was more like a
set
that um you would see on stage or
something like that so um
just keep those little things in mind as
you're watching these
but
i say all that to say
we ready fam we ready
so hit me uh
y'all ready for
[Applause]
[Music]
cool beans
and of course
all of our competitors
are
graduates of our comedy writing master
class so if you would like to compete in
next month's contest
i've pinned a link in the live chat
it's where you can go sign up for that
class
it's where you get to learn how to write
jokes organize them into a five minute
set and you also get to compete in this
every month so you're betting on
yourself
really
nice
all right well safe travels bain bear
bane bear said he's about to be driving
but he will be
um here for it
but without further ado my friends
the first comic up
previous winner this cat
has won a few times actually
and he's coming in
from
across
the pond
my friends and that is the one and only
jack allen everyone oh my god
[Music]
all right
so as we always say here
um
one second
[Applause]
your first competitor
mr jack
allen
it was terrible losing my first cat bob
yeah
it was like losing granddad only
more meaningful
but bob and grandad did have a lot in
common
their funerals were both
really
cheap you know
the couple's cat next door is always up
a tree
anything to get away from that terrible
marriage god
even whiskers the cat can smell
dysfunction
christ
but if you're in a terrible relationship
you have to sit down and talk
about getting a dog
yes
you can just ruffle those ears and let
it all
go i've been in a relationship for five
years at the wrong person but i'm too
lazy to find a new girlfriend
now dogs love owners with a balanced
lifestyle
not miserable enough for a divorce
but just sexist enough so there's space
in the bed
god nothing reignites that spark like
surrendering do they to a great dane
and
a polite dog will always ask
huh
will you be
having intercourse tonight
no oh
well i'll i'll
get involved then
yeah
keep it going for jack everyone
jack allen
great job buddy great job
that was a good set sorry my my 80d
there we go
just trying to
trying to get situated here
all right
oh look jerry said
nice jack ed rubin great job jack loved
the two cheap funerals
sandra doss great set jack
yes indeedy
that was a great set
good way to start it off we really came
out swinging here
is all i'll say so
it's gonna be a tight race i can feel it
already
um
[Music]
kaboom
oh joan like the dog in bed bit
uh
sandy said equally meaningful and cheap
get a dog love the dog act out some
space yeah yeah yeah
bob kirk nice set jack nice act outs
nice yeah yeah dino liked the
surrendering a duvet to a doberman yeah
that's fun fun little
word play there or alliteration or
consonants perhaps
sandra great set
yeah ed liked the two cheap funerals yes
good a lot of good writing in there a
lot of good writing
yeah this is going to be a tight race
now
but as you watch jack
put in the back your mind remember feel
free to take notes
as well like if something stands out or
something you want to remember for
voting
take notes on this and see what's good
in the hoodie
oh and jack said thank you guys yes yes
look at all the love and positivity
coming in here
but alas
we have arrived
to our next
competitor
my friends and that is going to be
the one and only jerry crowl my friends
so prepare yourselves
first time participant
in the hundred dollar joke contest
already in the finals so this is gonna
be a fun one
so without further ado my friends
prepare yourselves
for your next contestant
jerry
crowe
[Music]
we love our pets
and any animal is a pet to someone
you know we have dogs and cats
some people have mice as pets
other people have snakes as pets
which means that when you go into the
pet store all the cute mice they're in
the pet's aisle
all the ugly mice
they're in the food aisle
yeah
my neighbor runs a doggy day spa
those dogs look ridiculous in the white
terry cloth robes
and you should see them trying to get
the dogs to keep the cucumber slices on
their eyes
oh my kid we spoil our cat lord whiskers
you know my wife bought five cat trees
to find the right one
and it isn't just the right one for the
cat it's the right one that goes with
the room
so we spent another four thousand
dollars redecorating the room around the
cat tree
another seven hundred dollars on cat
toys
know the news said that people spent 110
billion dollars
on their pets last year
i think half of that was on my visa with
chewie.com yeah we took a three-day
vacation
chewy.com filed a missing persons report
on us
i gotta go get some
lord whiskers lobster pate time
yeah
keep it going
jerry crawl
first time competing my friends keep it
going
oh and i'm so glad his buddy pete goes
oh is this where i start heckling
hilarious
i feel you on chewy.com as well fam i
feel you on that
a missing person's
report lord whiskers ed ruben liked the
uh the lord whiskers and missing persons
report yeah yeah that missing person's
report was very silly
yeah a lot of good jokes in there though
jack liked the missing persons report
yeah
that is also a big benefit of competing
in this contest is if you get
to the finals
you get live feedback on your jokes
people always reply with what they liked
so then those are the kind of bits that
you can then build upon as well
it's kind of like last night
i started riffing about having marriage
shirts
so
like my spouse can find me in a crowd or
whatnot and just kind of having fun with
it but then after the shows
that was the joke people were coming up
and like saying to me they were like oh
this is his marriage shirt or a guy
would be like oh this is my marriage
shirt or whatnot so
that's kind of like live feedback we're
like oh there may be something there
that i can build upon and the same thing
here it's like if you get feedback on a
joke be like oh maybe i should go
further there and keep building on that
yeah joan liked the missing persons
report as well yeah so well i mean there
you go jerry
there you go my friend
so there's definitely something to build
upon there
oh he said thanks gang yeah yeah yeah
but don't say thanksgiving yet the
voting has not commenced but we are just
about to get into voting but
first things first and she just
commented saying funny jerry
we have our third and final finalist
of the august 100 dollar
joke
con
test
ladies and gentlemen
i actually got to meet this hot sister
in i don't know is that
hot brother and cistern hot breath or
should i just say breath or i don't want
to get canceled
hot breather got to meet her when i was
doing some shows up with other hop
breathers uh sandy bernstein show
got to got to meet this hilarious
chameleon that's going to be this next
finalist competitor
and without further ado my friends
prepare yourselves put on your thinking
caps and listen in the laughing caps now
for your final
contestant
of the august 100
joke contest
that is
sandra doss
hit the bell
ah excuse me
one second
kaboom
there we go
here we go
hi everybody
so i've always had pets in my life right
now i have two dogs a cordy and a french
bulldog
both understand commands in english and
in spanish which means that they can
ignore me in two languages
the corgis name is paprika
and this morning little paprika ate the
dog sitters
brownies
i think i'm gonna have to change
paprika's name to smoked paprika if you
know what i mean
the french's name is general custard and
that's because when we got him his paper
said cream boy
it suits him because he's turned it to
be quite a stud
general custard looks like the love
child of betty davis and winston
churchill
so both dogs are aggressive chewers
and the vet said get them bully sticks
so i did right now i don't know what
that is all i know is that it's
healthier than rawhide so i went and got
i didn't read the label but today i did
and i realized that it is 100
beef pistol
and that is
bull penis
i am feeding my darlings dehydrated bulb
dicks
van dyke
anyway
i'm not going to judge them
hey
i would much rather than eat penises if
they want to than my furniture
yeah keep it going
wait
there we go
keep it going for sandra doss everyone
if we could just get
just a loop
maybe we create like a gif of her just
going bull penis
great act outs there great voices and
animations there sandra very funny
oh and sandy said oh you mean the show
where
headliner joel got a standing ovation oh
i mean oh
i mean you know just just another day at
the office you know
you know we just out yeah
remaining one of comedy's best kept
secrets it's all gravy
um oh ed liked the bully stick stuff
yeah yeah yeah yeah
for chisel
yeah that was a good one
i'd never heard of that but that
definitely sounds true what's so crazy
now is a lot of dogs their food is
healthier
than um
than a lot of the human food my dog has
treats that are literally like four
ingredients and then i look at a bag of
chips
and there's like xantham gum and
glyphosate i was like geez did russia
hack our food
all right now we're running bits now
we're now we're getting to why we're
here today okay
now we're getting
to it
[Music]
oh let's see oh you know what's so funny
a few people commented and youtube
flagged the word
penis
that is so funny cause sandy said ignore
two languages smoke paprika bull penis
yeah and cynthia liked uh yeah sandra
dolls ooh penis
how funny
very fun bob kirk nice job sandra and
that's no bull
jerry kroll out here killing it
uh aaron despiva very funny sandra jack
allen great job sandra
that's what i love about this even the
competitors are showing each other love
because that's what this whole community
is about
uh jones said so funny sandra love the
ending and the betty davis and churchill
combo nice
la verada optimista
a general custard cream boy yeah yeah
sandy like that
uh la vera rana optimista di
uh hahaha boy so i don't know why i'm
doing in that accent
cynthia said no way it's a real body
part
i use the word everyday hilarious
i use the word penis every day jack
allen's your comment got
flagged too he said i can't stop
thinking about bull penis now i need
therapy hilarious
beautiful yeah dino liked it funny set
sandra good going yeah yeah yeah give
everyone honestly
give everyone a round of applause
seriously show love for all three
competitors because i'm telling you
right now
it is not easy
to do
this contest it is not easy to actually
have a random theme
write a brand new 90 second set
basically write and then refine and then
record i mean you
a lot of these a lot of competitors
record
10 20 50 takes of these sets like it is
not easy
to
even just submit to this but it is worth
it i will say because you get at the
very least
you get a brand new 90 second set out of
it
no what's the worst that could happen
there so
it's definitely uh it's definitely a
great challenge that holds people
accountable to write new jokes
oh and sandy said this is a tough one
yes indeed but
it is about that time my friends so i'm
about to post
the poll
and keep in mind as you're um
as you're voting keep in mind you know
how did they use the theme
and how funny is their set how many
laughs were in there you know really
really give this some serious thought
because this is for
a hundred
dollars
or
as me amigos
dolares
[Music]
i am going to post
the poll
the poll is now live my friends
the poll is now live so we're going
we're going to play we're going to play
a little music
we're going to play a little music
shadow
we're gonna play a little music
and the voting won't take long we're
just gonna take a minute here and
remember the winner gets to come on to
the show live right now for an interview
that's going to be posted on hot breath
podcast
and the winner gets 100 bucks there's a
lot at stake here so give it some
thought
give us some serious
hey
is the vote anonymous says pete well
jerry it sounds like pete is not voting
for you
uh but yes the voting is anonymous
pete
the voting is anonymous and right now it
is a toit
it is a
tight race look at that
oh my heavenly day 43
jack allen jerry kroll 36 sandra doss
dainty uno
hilarious
so just another minute here on the
voting so get your votes in get your
votes in get your votes in
vote for who you thought had the
funniest set
worthy of the hundred dollar prize
and i mean
more importantly an interview on hot
breath podcast i mean goodness gracious
we've interviewed over 400 comedians on
here do we even need to name them
let's look at our youtube channel
we can figure it out
all the top names in the game
and more to come as well
steve martin's about to retire i think
he would be a good person to you know
come on and reflect on his career no big
deal
but do subscribe to this channel man we
are revolutionizing comedies so join the
hot breath verse if you're new here
welcome aboard
and this monthly contest we do every
month
is for people that graduated from our
comedy writing master class so if you're
looking to learn more about how to write
jokes and structure them into a set
definitely
join that class that's linked at the top
of this live chat i pinned the link
there for y'all you can go join there
and then you get automatically entered
every month into this contest as well
and oh david came by it's crawl time go
buddy okay
time to wake up i didn't catch the jokes
but i voted anyway sounds like jerry
just did a text blast
you're not gonna believe this everyone
look at this
holy cow
right now we're in a three-way tie oh
jerry just pulled ahead
so let's do a quick countdown timer
sien dolares
frozen basic can relate to jerry's story
it was hard for us to match the carpet
of the cat tower to the carpet in the
bathroom at least the scents matched
hilarious
very nice
lunker steve go jerry okay we got a
jerry
fan club in here
so we're gonna just do
another minute
let's give one more minute
on the countdown on the countdown
on the on the on the on on the countdown
on the countdown
oh my gosh
it's a tight race right now it's jerry
croll
i'm gonna refresh
man i think this is our closest one yet
i think so
and this is jerry's in the lead even
though his friend
pete did not vote for him so
20 votes we got 26 people watching so if
you're watching this you haven't voted
go vote go vote go vote
and while you're at while you're at it
while you're clicking buttons subscribe
to this channel
while you're at it you're already
clicking buttons go ahead and subscribe
all right
have arrived my friends it appears
the hundred dollar joke contest winner
[Music]
is jerry kroll everyone is jerry kroll
the poll is closed shouty
the poll is closed it is jerry croll
congratulations jerry congratulations to
all three of you as well show some love
to jack and sandra as well this contest
is not easy
this contest is not easy
and
wow
that may be our closest competition yet
as well
it came in at 40 for jerry then jack had
30 and sandra had 30. so
a tight race
but alas the winner
mr jerry crowe mr jerry kroll
i'd like to invite you on the show live
now
and i sent you it via the facebook group
chat
and what i'm going to do here is go
ahead this is going to be a podcast on
tomorrow's podcast so i'm going to go
ahead and play
jerry's set i mean i'm gonna go ahead
and record the intro for it
no wait
i'll wait i'll wait till jerry gets here
and then i'll record it
and then yeah
that's what we'll do we'll wait for
jerry to get in here
oh yeah
this is gonna be so fun
jerry crow
coco coco
all right we're about to bring jerry in
one moment my friends
um
sanders said congrats jerry
said congrats jerry great job
uh
joan congrats jerry congrats jerry says
cynthia go sandra and jack yeah jack say
congratulate great stuff mate glad to
have you in hot breath i know a new
member
a new member
already winning this is gonna be so much
fun
oh my gosh
so we're about to bring jerry on here
this is going to be on tomorrow's
podcast as well so i'm going to record
the intro
and here we go
what's goodie hot breath the verse
welcome back to hot breath the show
where you learn comedy from the pros i
am your host
comedian joel byers and every month we
do a hundred dollar joke contest for
people in our comedy writing master
class
the winner gets a hundred bucks and an
interview on this podcast the challenge
is you get a new theme and you have to
write a new 90-second set based on that
theme and then we do a live stream
finale on our youtube channel which if
you're not subscribed do subscribe there
and our winner today is a first-time
participant and he already hit
a hundred dollars what a return on
investment
and welcome
your august 100 joke contest winner it
is the one and only
jerry kroll everyone give it up for
jerry
what's goodie jerry
not much man this is gonna cost me more
than 100 bucks based on all those people
who popped in the pole there yeah
especially your friend pete he seemed
like he's gonna hold you to it you know
actually he's the one who should have
been on here
oh is pete funny
pete's a funny guy gotta get him on
stage well you're funny as well congrats
on winning jerry thank you sir
and your your sister-in-law's in here
she said uh congratulations to my
brother-in-law tammy so
oh wow her name's tammy yeah that i
believe i remember her from the wedding
yeah oh okay he said he said i was like
wait do you know is this
an ex-in-law cool
so
jerry congratulations man i'm so i'm so
excited i'm proud of you please take us
through here
um i want to get into how you wrote this
set but also to give the hot breath of
verse a little background on your comedy
experience how you got to where you are
to become world famous now
oh i tell you the the hot breath verse i
mean
it's the universe right that's right
yeah i guess it started all in the
fallopian tube i was swimming along
um
we're gonna get demonetized now we said
fallopian
no i don't know i've always kind of been
this way
uh
you know fifth grade had to write
stories and i would always write funny
stories read them in a weird voice that
kind of thing uh 16 years old in high
school
uh was in a show choir and my first solo
was doing comedy because that's how good
of a singer i was
so now that was i tell you being 16
years old and we had a fairly big high
school in that that show choir they
they were kind of a big thing just like
you know joel buyers
and uh
first time yes first time i'm doing a
show
it's like 800 or a thousand people oh
i'm 16. i've never done
any kind of stand up
but you get that many people laughing
yeah you're hooked
for sure so did you just jump into
stand-up like what it you know i after
after that series of shows that we did i
only waited about 30 years before i got
back on stage
[Music]
but i did second city in chicago when i
was a little bit older uh some people
there started to do stand-up and i did
the writing program when they first
started it so
some of these uh guys who were doing
stand up would send me stuff they knew
me from the writing program say hey can
you help me with this stuff so i was
punching up helping people punch up
stand up and they kept saying you got to
get on stage you got to get on stage
and i really waited i
would pop in at open mics for my job i
travel all over so i'd pop in open mics
you know tell a funny story or something
but i didn't actually
really pursue it until
about a year ago i
took a class moved to phoenix from
chicago and i took a class at a comedy
club and you know at the end of it you
do your showcase spot
[Music]
i got
booked for a
show doing a showcase spot in a clean
comedy show got paid for that he booked
me again a couple months later and it's
like
i got to get more material
yeah it is funny you know
it's been great i
writing sketch writing stand up and then
my friends and my family are hilarious
so basically i can just bounce stuff off
them so when how long ago did you start
what year was it that you like started
stand up like consistently really just
last year last year okay i i was doing
stuff i was helping a lot of other
comedians uh
they would send me stuff and i would
punch it up but me actually getting on
stage was just last year just last year
well very nice jerry yeah the writing
shows too is very funny um how did you
the so the theme is pets
so like how what did you what did you do
like where do you start now that you
know the theme and then yeah how did you
finalize it into this like winning set
the first thing
i
i i'm more of a free writer right off
the bat so i come up with something
and
because i've been doing this so long i
actually just start by typing and i type
into a format
so
you know i've got
setup setup punch
right as i'm writing i decide
what i think is a setup what i think is
a punch what i think is a tag
and
then i just start going back through and
editing and saying okay am i starting
out with too many setup lines do i have
too many setup lines is this really
funny run it by my wife she tells me
nothing is funny so then
that's what you know it's a keeper
yeah yeah i tear it up and go back i
mean there's there's nobody to
bring you down you know like family
especially yeah we need it
she's she won't even listen to this
right now hilarious that that's what
when um when uh
when sandy won last month i think her
husband went for a walk he was just like
just hey
she's like why do you always sound so
mad when you get on stage you sound mad
and you act you're too hammy i'm like
i'm new give me any time you'll get
there yeah you'll get there buddy no
doubt so you start out free writing you
basically just get a bunch of ideas out
on the page and then you start to edit
them into like joke format i guess yep
yep
basically joke format i mean my first
version
started out with
uh and i researched it says americans
spent 110 billions on their pets last
year cancer research research was 7.4
billion 7.4 billion for curing cancer
compared to 110 billion for squeaky toys
ah really not really a joke more of a
hey look look at this ridiculous
difference
but i like the americans spent 110
billion and that ended up turning into
the whole thing about chewy.com yeah
so where you you know you talk about it
in the course
where you save a line at least one part
of it and then you can build a whole
different joke off of it so yeah a lot
of that this was uh
according to my paper this was three
versions technically four
because when i recorded it it was 10
seconds too long so i had to dump a
couple lines
yeah and it's interesting you said
um
you pivoted you changed the punch line
to make it more personal and that's what
ended up working like at first it was
like a clever observation and then
you're like all right how can i make it
uniquely me and make it about my life
and that's the one you ended up keeping
right and it ended up being basically
the closing joke which everybody
to like and i loved how it built too
because you start with 110 billion
so okay set it up there that people
spend a lot of money
half of it was on my visa card okay
there's joke number one
and then uh going on a vacation and they
filed a missing person to report and
it's like oh that's the one that really
landed so
yeah how many jokes do you think you
wrote to get to this 90 seconds like you
said this was three drafts at least of
the final set but how much did you have
to write to get there
they're probably if i would have read
them all out and you know none of them
not all of them being good there
probably were
30 or 40
and then you just start throwing them up
but the great thing is again because i
write using the computer i've got all
those other ones i've got every version
saved i say you know though i've got 14
15 versions of bits
and when i'm thinking of something new
it's like oh wait that old joke that i
threw out of that one i gotta find that
and i can bring it back in
yeah i know that george carlin was known
to like he would categorize folders on
his computer
based on topics so he could quickly
reference them yeah
yeah yeah i'm a comedy nerd like that so
i just i
diving into hot breath and all the
interviews and everything i love
listening
and and hearing about these guys and how
they write you know bill burr basically
goes on stage and just does it
yeah i never do that never do that
uh brian regan one of my favorites
everything is scripted out and i i love
you can watch him and i when i talk to
people you know who asked me about how
do you write comedy and you know
are you just up there making it up and
it's like no i said
watch brian regan something that he did
20 years ago and when he does his
encores people ask to do something he
does it almost word for word
facial expression same thing and and it
still works
yeah
even if you heard it that's when you
know it's a good joke if like you've
heard it 10 times and you still laugh
yeah
yeah for sure
well if people want to
come see you do a show where they want
to follow you or whatnot like what what
can you promote here jerry what do you
anything people follow you or whatnot
right no i moved into a house about a
month ago so that picture just went up
yesterday
for the just in case you won you're like
let me put up some artists
my wife was like what do you think what
what are you
do you want to put
yeah okay
hey
but now the hundred dollars yeah that's
more cat toys i'm sure we'll frame that
yo that'll go to the chewy that'll all
go to chewy hilarious
um
if people want to want to reach out to
me uh jerry underscore cruel k-r-u-l-l
on twitter uh i've got a linkedin one
just for the comedy look at the one
that's comedy because i have a separate
one for real business
uh
yeah and facebook the people in the
group if they want to reach out to me on
facebook perfect yeah and i will link
that in the um i'm just writing those
down i'll link that in the show notes
for you
as well for people yeah i mean we're all
about comics helping comics so if you
hear this
go shout out jerry go reach out to him
and let him know how cool this was to
hear him on the show because this i just
love this first time participant and you
knocked it out of the park fam i'm
excited for you
thanks
applause applause
well jerry congratulations my friend
and um we're gonna land this plane i'm
gonna go do some planting i have more
gardening to do i know in arizona you
definitely don't i was just out there
like two weeks ago and there's and i
missed that you were 20 minutes away
from me uh my son got married and so the
day you flew in and your first show was
maybe you know thursday i flew out and
then i came back on the sunday
yeah
you peace i've done the open mic there a
couple of times and that thursday night
did you stay at all for any of that um
no because i went to see miss pat miss
pat was in town so i went yeah i went to
see her but i would have otherwise
though
first time i did that he did it as a
contest
it went until
one in the morning there was
40 to 50 people i was like number 14
and luckily i had taken the next day off
work so i stuck around oh my god gosh
the people don't get any more sober
because it goes
and if people are out that late drinking
on a sunday they they're hiding from
something and in arizona they're on
witness protection for sure right people
are just hiding
right
yeah and you get some of those guys at
the end i don't even think they realize
that they're there anymore
one guy did a drug bit that i swear it
was just really him asking for drugs
hilarious
but dude i mean that's part of the the
comedy grind that people don't see and
that's part of people who do start who
maybe think they're above uh especially
starting out it's that's all
par for the course in comedy we've all
been through that
yeah yeah did you like sharing the
bathroom with the uh everybody else the
green room back there yeah it was great
yeah yeah it was cool
you're getting ready to go on or maybe
you just you know you're waiting for
your second show and you've got
everybody coming in and it's like hey
this is not the time to talk yeah i was
just selling merch i was out there i was
selling like toilet paper that was my
merch for the show
yeah it was very fun jp was a great club
and
it's great it's what's cool about your
story as well is you said 40 or 50
people i mean like the scene in arizona
i was out there i did a local comics
podcast as well like i got i got a good
sense of the scene there's a great scene
out there in arizona yeah yeah they're
doing a lot of comedy all around i mean
i did it i didn't do it the thing at
jp's i did one in uh glendale place
called stir crazy
yeah yeah yeah yeah there's a lot of and
what's great is all these comedians that
i reach out to on twitter like dennis
regan josh snead i've met a lot of these
guys and have talked with them and
they're really nice people i'm sure you
are too joel um
so far so good right
yeah yeah yeah so you know they've been
really kind you know take pictures and
stuff and a lot of the dry bar people
come through here and but there's so
many places that are doing comedy um if
you can't find time you know state some
stage time then you're just not trying
boom
bars
well jerry crowe man it's so great to uh
officially speak to you
in person virtually ish and uh
congratulations man i'm excited for you
thank you sir
all right well have a good day out there
buddy all right youtube bye y'all
[Music]
all right wait wait oh my gosh i'm lost
all right everyone
that was it
go forth with the old days my friends if
you would like to hear yourself on the
podcast perhaps next month all you gotta
do is join our comedy writing master
class where you get access to the class
and free entry into this contest every
month to win 100 bucks and be on the
show
i love you all so much
and now until next monday
right here on
hot
brush
yeah
awesome
thanks for hanging out y'all dude that
was
that was legit i was just recording the
outro for the podcast there but that was
super dope and it was cool to see
jerry and you know this wasn't this
wasn't by accident i mean this guy's
been studying comedy he's been a
practitioner
of comedy so
yeah it makes sense you know that he's
putting in the work and the work is
paying off that's the name of the game
my friends so
i love you all so much but we must land
this plane i told my wife
i would be done at 11
because
i don't even want to tell you
i mean
i don't want to say 50 plants but i
don't want to not say that that's not
how many
and i ain't even flexing shouty maybe
30.
no she has 50 bulbs and 30 plants we're
planting so
we're going to land this plane
but i love y'all so much i really do
appreciate y'all hanging out it's a
sunday time is our most valuable
resource
and the fact you spend it here i'm just
eternally grateful for so
thank you all so much for hanging out
and um
i'll have a good day out there okay
okay
have a good day
and we will see you on tuesday for the
joke feedback hour my friends
have a good day
bye y'all
[Music]
wow
my
[Music]
you